this is a video about one of the most
important yet least understood Concepts
in all of physics it governs everything
from molecular collisions to humongous
storms from the beginning of the
universe through its entire Evolution to
its inevitable end it may in fact
determine the direction of time and even
be the reason that life exists to see
the confusion around this topic you need
to ask only one simple question
what does the Earth get from the Sun
what does the Earth get from Sun
um well it's light rays what do we get
from heat
warmth warm light vitamin D we get
vitamin D we do get vitamin D from the
ultraviolet rays well
a lot of energy what is the Earth get
from this energy yes energy energy
nailed it every day the Earth gets a
certain amount of energy from the Sun
and then how much energy does the Earth
radiate back into space relative to that
amount that it gets from the Sun
probably not as much you know I don't
believe it it's just radiating right
back I'd say less less say less I guess
about 70 percent it is a fraction I'd
say 20 because because we use some of it
we use some of the energy we consume a
lot right but the thing about energy is
it never really goes away you can't
really use it up
it would have to break even wouldn't it
same amount yeah you know cause and
effect it'd be equal in some ways right
for most of the Earth's history it
should be exactly the same amount of
energy in from the Sun as Earth radiates
into space
wow because if we didn't do that then
the Earth would get a lot hotter that'd
be a problem that'd be a big problem so
if that is the case yeah then what are
we really getting from the Sun
that's a good question
it gives us a nice 10. it gives us a
nice tan I love it we're getting
something special from the Sun I don't
know what do we get what without the
energy but nobody talks about it
to answer that we have to go back to a
discovery made two centuries ago
in the winter of 1813 France was being
invaded by the armies of Austria Prussia
and Russia the son of one of Napoleon's
generals was Sadi Carnot a 17 year old
student on December 29th he writes a
letter to Napoleon to request to join in
the fight Napoleon preoccupied in battle
never replies
but Carnot gets his wish a few months
later when Paris is attacked the
students defend a chateau just east of
the city but they're no match for the
advancing armies in Paris Falls after
only a day of fighting
forced to retreat Carnot is devastated
seven years later he goes to visit his
father who's fled to Prussia after
Napoleon's downfall
his father was not only a general but
also a physicist he wrote an essay on
how energy is most efficiently
transferred in mechanical systems
when his son comes to visit they talk at
length about the big breakthrough of the
time steam engines steam engines were
already being used to power ships mine
ore and excavate ports and it was clear
that the future industrial and Military
might of Nations depended on having the
best steam engines
but French designs were falling behind
those of other countries like Britain so
Sadi Carnot took it upon himself to
figure out why
at the time even the best steam engines
only converted around three percent of
thermal energy into useful mechanical
work if he could improve on that he
could give France a huge advantage and
restore its place in the world so he
spends the next three years studying
heat engines and one of his key insights
involves how an ideal heat engine would
work one with no friction and no losses
to the environment it looks something
like this
take two really big metal bars one hot
and one cold the engine consists of a
chamber filled with air where heat can
only flow in or out through the bottom
inside the chamber is a piston which is
connected to a flywheel the air starts
at a temperature just below that of the
hot bar so first the hot bar is brought
into contact with the chamber the air
inside expands with heat flowing into it
to maintain its temperature this pushes
the Piston up turning the flywheel next
the hot bar is removed but the air in
the chamber continues to expand except
now without heat entering the
temperature decreases in the ideal case
until it is the temperature of the cold
bar the cold bar is brought into contact
with the chamber and the flywheel pushes
the Piston down and as the air is
compressed heat is transferred into the
cold bar
the cold bar is removed the flywheel
compresses the gas further increasing
its temperature until it is just below
that of the hot bar then the hot bar is
connected again and the cycle repeats
through this process heat from the hot
bar is converted into the energy of the
flywheel
and what's interesting to note about
carno's ideal engine is that it is
completely reversible if you ran the
engine in Reverse first the air expands
lowering the temperature then the
chamber is brought into contact with the
cold bar the air expands more drawing in
heat from the cold bar next the air is
compressed increasing its temperature
the chamber is placed on top of the hot
bar and the energy of the flywheel is
used to return the heat back into the
hot bar
however many cycles were run in the
forward Direction you could run the same
number in reverse and at the end
everything would return to its original
state with no additional input of energy
required so by running an ideal engine
nothing really changes you can always
undo what you did
so what is the efficiency of this engine
since it's fully reversible you might
expect the efficiency to be 100 percent
but that is not the case each cycle the
energy of the flywheel increases by the
amount of heat flowing into the Chamber
from the hot bar
minus the heat flowing out of the
chamber at the cold bar
so to calculate the efficiency we divide
this energy by the heat input from the
hot bar
now the heat in on the hot side is equal
to the work done by the gas on the
piston and this will always be greater
than the work done by the piston on the
gas on the cold side which equals the
heat out and this is because on the hot
side the hot gas exerts a greater
pressure on the Piston than that same
gas when cold
to increase the efficiency of the engine
you could increase the temperature of
the hot side or decrease the temperature
of the cold side or both
Lord Kelvin learns of carnot's Ideal
heat engine and realizes it could form
the basis for an absolute temperature
scale
imagine that the gas is allowed to
expand an extreme amount so much that it
cools to the point where all the gas
particles effectively stop moving
then they would exert no pressure on the
piston and it would take no work to
compress it on the cold side so no heat
would be lost this is the idea of
absolute zero and it would make for a
100 percent efficient engine
using this absolute temperature scale
the Kelvin scale we can replace the
amount of heat in and out with the
temperature of the hot and cold side
respectively because they are directly
proportional so we can express
efficiency like this which we can
rewrite like this
what we have learned is that the
efficiency of an ideal heat engine
doesn't depend on the materials or the
design of the engine but fundamentally
on the temperatures of the hot and cold
sides to reach 100 efficiency you need
infinite temperature on the hot side or
absolute zero on the cold side both of
which are impossible in practice so even
with no friction or losses to the
environment it's impossible to make a
heat engine a hundred percent efficient
and that's because to return the Piston
to its original position you need to
dump heat into the cold bar so not all
the energy stays in the flywheel
now in car knows time high pressure
steam engines could only reach
temperatures up to 160 degrees Celsius
so their theoretical maximum efficiency
was 32 percent but their real efficiency
was more like three percent that's
because real engines experience friction
dissipate heat to the environment and
they don't transfer heat at constant
temperatures so for just as much heat
going in less energy ends up in the
flywheel the rest is spread out over the
walls of the cylinder the axle of the
flywheel and is radiated out into the
environment
when energy spreads out like this it is
impossible to get it back so this
process is irreversible the total amount
of energy didn't change but it became
less usable energy is most usable when
it is concentrated and less usable when
it's spread out
decades later German physicist Rudolf
clausius studies carnot's engine and he
comes up with a way to measure how
spread out the energy is
he calls this quantity entropy
when all the energy is concentrated in
the hot bar that is low entropy but as
the energy spreads to the surroundings
the walls of the chamber and the axle
will entropy increases this means the
same amount of energy is present but in
this more dispersed form it is less
available to do work
in 1865 clausius summarizes the first
two laws of thermodynamics like this
first the energy of the universe is
constant
second the entropy of the universe tends
to a maximum
in other words energy spreads out over
time
[Music]
the second law is core to so many
phenomena in the world it's why hot
things cool down and cool things heat up
why gas expands to fill a container why
you can't have a perpetual motion
machine because the amount of usable
energy in a closed system is always
decreasing
the most common way to describe entropy
is as disorder which makes sense because
it is associated with things becoming
more mixed random and less ordered but I
think the best way to think about
entropy is as the tendency of energy to
spread out so why does energy spread out
over time I mean most of the laws of
physics work exactly the same way
forwards or backwards in time so how
does this clear time dependence arise
well let's consider two small metal bars
one hot and one cold for this simple
model we'll consider only eight atoms
per bar
each atom vibrates according to the
number of energy packets it has the more
packets the more it vibrates so let's
start with seven packets of energy in
the left bar and three in the right the
number of energy packets in each bar is
what we'll call a state
first let's consider just the left bar
it has seven energy packets which are
free to move around the lattice this
happens non-stop the energy packets hop
randomly from atom to Adam giving
different configurations of energy but
the total energy stays the same the
whole time
now let's bring the cold bar back in
with only three packets and touch them
together the energy packets can now hop
around between both bars creating
different configurations
each unique configuration is equally
likely
so what happens if we take a snapshot at
one instant in time and see where all
the energy packets are
so stop
look at this now there are nine energy
packets in the left bar and only one in
the right bar so heat has flowed from
cold to hot
shouldn't that be impossible because it
decreases entropy
well this is where Ludwig boltzmann made
an important Insight heat flowing from
cold to hot is not impossible it's just
improbable
there are 91 520 configurations with
nine energy packets in the left bar but
627 264 with five energy packets in each
bar that is the energy is more than six
times as likely to be evenly spread
between the bars
but if you add up all the possibilities
you find there's still a 10.5 percent
chance that the left bar ends up with
more energy packets than it started
so why don't we observe this happening
around us
we'll watch what happens as we increase
the number of atoms to 80 per bar and
the energy packets to a hundred with 70
in the left bar and 30 in the right
there is now only a point zero five
percent chance that the left solid ends
up hotter than it started and this trend
continues as we keep scaling up the
system in everyday solids there are
around a hundred trillion trillion atoms
and even more energy packets so heat
flowing from cold to hot is just so
unlikely that it never happens
think of it like this Rubik's cube right
now it is completely solved but I'm
going to close my eyes and make some
turns at random
if I keep doing this it will get further
and further from being solved but how
can I be confident that I'm really
messing this Cube up well because
there's only one way for it to be solved
a few ways for it to be almost solved
and quintillions of ways for it to be
almost entirely random without thought
and effort every turn moves the Rubik's
Cube from a highly unlikely state that
of it being solved to a more likely
State a total mess
so if the natural tendency of energy is
to spread out and for things to get
Messier then how is it possible to have
something like air conditioning where
the cold interior of a house gets cooler
and the hot exterior gets hotter
[Music]
energy is going from cold to hot
decreasing the entropy of the house
well this decrease in entropy is only
possible by increasing the entropy a
greater amount somewhere else in this
case at a power plant the concentrated
chemical energy and coal is being
released heating up the power plant in
its environment spreading to the turbine
the electric generators heating the
wires all the way to the house and
producing waste heat in the fans and
compressor
whatever decrease in entropy is achieved
at the house is more than paid for by an
increase in entropy required to make
that happen
but if total entropy is constantly
increasing and anything we do only
accelerates that increase then how is
there any structure left on Earth
how are their hot Parts separate from
cold Parts how does life exist
well if the Earth were a closed system
the energy would spread out completely
meaning all life would cease everything
would Decay and mix and eventually reach
the same temperature
but luckily Earth is not a closed system
because we have the Sun
[Music]
what the sun really gives us is a steady
stream of low entropy that is
concentrated bundled up energy the
energy that we get from the Sun is more
useful
than the energy we give back it's more
compact it's more clumped together
plants capture this energy and use it to
grow and create sugars then animals eat
plants and use that energy to maintain
their bodies and move around
bigger animals get their energy by
eating smaller animals and so on and
each step of the way the energy becomes
more spread out okay interesting yeah oh
wow I did not know that there you go
ultimately all the energy that reaches
Earth from the Sun is converted into
thermal energy and then it's radiated
back into space
but in fact it's the same amount
I know this is you you do know this is
I'm a PhD physicist okay anyway I trust
you
the increase in entropy can be seen in
the relative number of photons arriving
at and leaving the Earth
for each Photon received from the Sun
20 photons are emitted and everything
that happens on Earth plants growing
trees falling herds stampeding
hurricanes and tornadoes people eating
sleeping and breathing all of it happens
in the process of converting fewer
higher energy photons into 20 times as
many lower energy photons
without a source of concentrated energy
and a way to discard the spread out
energy life on Earth would not be
possible
it has even been suggested that life
itself may be a consequence of the
second law of Thermodynamics if the
universe tends toward maximum entropy
then life offers a way to accelerate
that natural tendency because life is
spectacularly good at converting low
entropy into high entropy
for example the surface layer of
seawater produces between 30 to 680
percent more entropy when cyanobacteria
and other organic matter is present than
when it's not
Jeremy England takes this one step
further he's proposed that if there is a
constant stream of clumped up energy
this could favor structures that
dissipate that energy and over time this
results in better and better energy
dissipators eventually resulting in Life
or in his own words you start with a
random clump of atoms and if you shine
light on it for long enough it should
not be so surprising that you get a
plant
so life on Earth survives on the low
entropy from the Sun
but then where did the Sun get its low
entropy
the answer is the universe
if we know that the total entropy of the
universe is increasing with time then it
was lower entropy yesterday and even
lower entropy the day before that and so
on all the way back to the Big Bang
so right after the big bang that is when
the entropy was lowest this is known as
the past hypothesis it doesn't explain
why the entropy was low just that it
must have been that way for the universe
to unfold as it has
but the early Universe was hot dense and
almost completely uniform I mean
everything was mixed and the temperature
was basically the same everywhere
varying by at most point zero zero one
percent so how is this low entropy
well the thing we've left out is gravity
gravity tends to Clump matter together
so taking gravity into account having
matter all spread out like this would be
an extremely unlikely State and that is
why it's low entropy
over time as the universe expanded and
cooled matter started to Clump together
in more dense regions and in doing so
enormous amounts of potential energy
were turned into kinetic energy
and this energy could also be used like
how water flowing downhill can power a
turbine
but as bits of matter started hitting
each other some of their kinetic energy
was converted into heat so the amount of
useful energy decreased thereby
increasing entropy over time the useful
energy was used in doing so stars
planets galaxies and life were formed
increasing entropy all along
the universe started with around 10 to
the 88 boltzmann constants worth of
entropy nowadays all the stars in the
observable universe have about 9.5 times
10 to the 80. the interstellar and
Intergalactic medium combined have
almost 10 times more but still only a
fraction of the early universe
a lot more is contained in neutrinos and
in photons of the cosmic microwave
background
in 1972 Jacob beckenstein proposed
another source of entropy
black holes
he suggested that the entropy of a black
hole should be proportional to its
surface area so as a black hole grows
its entropy increases
famous physicists thought the idea was
nonsense and for good reason according
to classical thermodynamics if black
holes have entropy then they should also
have a temperature but if they have
temperatures they should emit radiation
and not be black after all
the person who set out to prove
beckenstein wrong was Stephen Hawking
but to his surprise his results showed
that black holes do emit radiation now
known as Hawking radiation and they do
have a temperature
the black hole at the center of the
Milky Way has a temperature of about 100
trillionth of a Kelvin emitting
radiation that is far too weak to detect
so still pretty black but Hawking
confirmed that black holes have entropy
and beckenstein was right Hawking was
able to refine beckenstein's proposal
and determine just how much entropy they
have the supermassive black hole at the
center of the Milky Way has about 10 to
the 91 boltzmann constants of entropy
that is a thousand times as much as the
early observable universe and 10 times
more than all the other particles
combined
and that is just one black hole all
black holes together account for three
times ten to the 104 boltzmann constants
worth of entropy
so almost all the entropy of the
universe is tied up in black holes that
means the early Universe only had about
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero three
percent of the entropy it has now
so the entropy was low and everything
that happens in the universe like
planetary systems forming galaxies
merging asteroids crashing Stars dying
to life itself flourishing all of that
can happen because the entropy of the
universe was low and it has been
increasing
and it all happens only in One Direction
we never see an asteroid uncrash or a
planetary system unmix into the cloud of
dust and gas that made it up there is a
clear difference between going to the
past and the future and that difference
comes from entropy the fact that we are
going from unlikely to more likely
States is why there is an arrow of time
this is expected to continue until
eventually the energy gets spread out so
completely that nothing interesting will
ever happen again this is the heat death
of the universe
in the distant future more than 10 to
the hundred years from now after the
last black hole has evaporated the
universe will be in its most probable
state
now even on large scales you would not
be able to tell the difference between
time moving forwards or backwards and
the arrow of time itself would disappear
so it sounds like entropy is this awful
thing that leads us inevitably towards
the dullest outcome imaginable
just because maximum entropy has low
complexity does not mean that low
entropy has maximum complexity it's
actually more like this tea and milk I
mean holding it like this is not very
interesting but as I pour the milk in
the two start to mix and these beautiful
patterns emerge they arise in an instant
and before you know it they're gone back
to being featureless both low and high
entropy are low in complexity it's in
the Middle where complex structures
appear and Thrive and since that's where
we find ourselves let's make use of the
low entropy we've got while we can
with the right tools we can understand
just about anything from a cup of tea
cooling down to the evolution of the
entire universe and if you're looking
for a free and easy way to add powerful
tools to Your Arsenal then you should
check out this video's sponsor
brilliant.org with brilliant you can
master key Concepts in everything from
math and data science to programming and
physics all you need to do is set your
goal and Brilliant will Design the
perfect learning path for you equipping
you with all the tools you need to reach
it want to learn how to think like a
programmer then brilliant's latest
course thinking in code is a fast and
easy way to get there using an intuitive
drag and drop editor it teaches you what
you really need to know including
essential Concepts like nesting and
conditionals you can start by jumping
right in to program a robot and then
learn how to apply your new tools to
your everyday life like automating
reminders on your phone or building a
bot that filters your matches on a
dating app what I love about brilliant
is that they connect what you learn to
real world examples and because each
lesson is Hands-On you'll build real
intuition so you can put what you've
learned to good use to try everything
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit brilliant.org veritasium I
will put that link down in the
description and through that link the
first 200 of you to sign up will get 20
off Brilliance annual premium
subscription so I want to thank
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
I want to thank you for watching